This episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war funder.
Check out this game through the
link in the description below.
Go through that link and you
not only support this show,
but you also get a free premium tank or
aircraft and three days of premium time
as a bonus and let's get into it.
Okay.
Here's the only person who's baby picture
was flown into space and whose body
has been preserved for
decades after his death.
He pushed his version of communism so
far and for so long that he was able to
overthrow the governments of the
largest country in the world. To some,
he's a hero to others.
He is one of the most evil villains in
history and today's biographics graphics
video.
We're talking about Vladimir Lenin,
the man behind the Bolshevik revolution
and the founder of the Soviet Union
via was 1870 and Vladimir Ilyich,
Oregon [inaudible] was born in a Russian
provincial town called Sim bisque.
He would later grew up to be
known by his alias Vladimir Lenin.
Am I going to explain that later
in the video? Most revolutionaries,
they've got this tragic backstory.
If a young life of hardship rising
from the lower classes to demand better
treatments for the down trodden and many
people are taught that this is the case
with Lennon as well.
They try to say that his parents were
descended from surfs and theirs have to
study hard to break into the middle class,
but the truth is that then ins patterns,
they were actually financially comfortable
and by all accounts he had a happy
childhood. His mother, Maria,
she was descended from a wealthy
Jewish family who is Swiss German,
so she taught him French
and German at home.
His father was the director of public
schools for the entire province.
They were considered to be
hereditary nobility, yams.
They were far more educated than the
average Russian. This place does.
Parents in a group cools
the intelligentsia who would
debate over philosophy and
politics in their spare time.
Many of the members of the
intelligentsia became politicians.
You helped shape the new laws of the
nation while others devoted their life to
pushing for a Russian revolution.
Vladimir and his older brother, Alexander,
they wouldn't no exception. His brother
loves studying science in high school,
but there were no opportunities to
become a scientist in this small Russian
village. So Alexandra and moved to
Saint Petersburg to attend university.
During this time,
he joined a political study groupings.
They began to discuss the failures of
the Romanov Empire and they believe that
the only way to say of Russia
would be to remove them from power.
When he was 21 years olds,
Alexander joined a terrorist group who
attempted to assassinate saw Nicholas the
second with a homemade bomb,
the terrorists,
they were caught and Alexandra and his
friends, they were hanged for that crime.
Vladimir Lenin was 17 at the time that
his brother died and he was just about to
graduate from high school.
Even though we had gone through
such a shocking tragedy,
he still managed to become the
Valedictorian of his graduating class.
He went to law school with the
intention of becoming a lawyer,
but just a few months
into his first semester,
he joined the demonstration of students
who were protesting against the school
rules.
Soon as the Russian police were already
watching Lennon closely to see if he was
also a terrorist like his brother.
The school saw his participation in these
demonstrations as a sign that he might
cause a lot of trouble in the future,
so he was expelled and he decided
to educate himself instead.
The Song Nicholas,
the seconds he released the peasant
class from their surf status,
meaning that they no longer have to be
indentured servants to wealthy landowners.
While this helps relieve the
difficulties of a lot of people,
it wasn't really a perfect solution to
the problems that this hasn't passed.
We're facing people.
They were still in debt since many
struggles to just make ends meet.
The vast majority of people,
they were illiterate and Russia was
decades behind in progress compared to the
western world.
Many members of the intelligentsia,
they were unhappy with the way things
were going and wanted their country to
move forward with progress just like
the rest of the human race. Man.
He studied Laura at school,
but he realized that with his bad nerves
and his family's bad reputation from
his brother being a terrorist,
it would be impossible for him to get
a job as a lawyer. Vladimir Lenin,
he began his self education by reading
Karl Marx and other revolutionary writers.
He joined the Marxist Study
Group were intellectuals,
Matt and discussed philosophy and the
possibility of a Russian revolution.
It was around this time
that a major famine spread
throughout the lands near his
home records of the 1891 famine.
They vary drastically.
Some say that the way 300,000 deaths,
while others say it was closer to
5 million people, then he was fine.
Of course it's family. They were well off
as you had plenty of money to buy food,
but he also didn't nothing to aid
the people who were dying around him.
He was actually kind of happy about this,
saying that the worst
things got in Russia,
the better it would ultimately become.
He knew that people needed to start dying
in the thousands before people would
be angry enough to want to revolution
call Mark's right that he believes an
industrialized society would be the most
likely to create a revolution because
he believes that they'd want to
rise up against commercialism.
Vladimir Lenin rewrote a lot of
what Mark's was actually saying.
Lenin wrote the idea
that the revolutionary
intelligentsia will guide the
uneducated peasants,
even though the philosophy was labeled
as Marxism all throughout the reign of
the Soviet Union,
it is now called Leninism because it
really was his own personal ideas and not
those of Karl Marx.
Lenin joined a socialist group that
gained access to a factory there.
They started handing out
fliers to factory workers.
They weren't trying to make people angry
about their work situations and wanted
them to demand shorter
hours and higher pay.
They were caught though because they
accidentally allowed a police informant
joining the group and they
were all arrested at this time,
any form of revolutionary activity.
It was taken very seriously and
they all had to serve jail time.
He was 26 years old at the time.
You went to prison,
but there was nothing like what weird.
Imagine a Russian prison to be.
Since he descended from
a Nobel blood line,
he was given a very comfortable place
to live where he could wear whatever
clothes he wants,
his as well as read books,
and he also received a daily
visits from his family and friends.
He was even allowed to continue writing
his revolutionary pamphlets and essays
while he was behind bars for that very
activity. After just 14 months in jail,
he was exiled to Siberia for
three more years. In a way though,
this was actually a good move for him.
He was given a government pension
that covered his living expenses.
This meant he spent most of his time
meeting and writing about the revolution,
which is what he would be doing anyway,
so for him this time in Siberia,
it was more like a very long writer's
retreat and he was actually very
productive during his time away.
Indeed,
his girlfriend was also arrested
and sent to Siberia as well.
They got married there so that
they could live in exile together.
So Vladimir Lenin,
he's raising these revolutionary ideas
in Siberia and he's sending them back to
a socialist friends who are publishing
his essays in a secret newspaper.
He made up a variety of different pen
names so that it seems like multiple
intellectuals were all pushing
for the same revolution,
but really it was just him.
The bad name here eventually
stuck with was Vladimir Lenin,
which is what he is remembered us today
after being released from his time at
Exxon, he was 30 years old and he and
his wife moved to Munich, Germany,
where they could print revolutionary
newspapers in Russian without getting into
trouble with the German police.
He would then have the papers smuggled
into Russia with the help of fellow
revolutionaries who carried
them in their luggage.
One of these co-conspirators was a young
man named Joseph Stalin who was equally
passionate about the coming revolution
and would eventually take Lennon's place.
Now, just before we get into
the next spot of Lennon's life,
I do want to mention
today's sponsor war thunder.
Thunder is a realistic free
to play vehicle combat game.
And I know that the advert in the
middle of the video is not ideal,
but we can do subjects
like this without sponsors.
This video has themes that
you advertising. Advertisers
just don't really like.
So without a sponsor we can't really pay
for it. So thank you for watching this
smell. This one says it's also free, it's
also a game. So that's also pretty great.
Now it always amazes me when I hear
that there aren't millions of players of
these online games, millions.
So it's a lot of people.
But then I can see why it's amazing
what games can do these days,
especially free games. It's free
to play. It looks incredible.
Just look at the footage we're
showing here. I mean, why not?
In this game there are over 1,200
historically accurate vehicles.
There are tanks,
aircraft ships,
incredible vehicles
from the 1930s onwards.
So this game is available
on PC ps four and Xbox one.
So join us on the battlefield for free.
Using the link below,
doing that support to this show.
And it also gets you your free premium
tanker aircraft and three days of premium
time as a bonus for registering.
Yeah.
Rolling.
Yeah,
and most tellings of
the Russian revolution.
Vladimir London's rise to power
always seems very straight forward.
He is always depicted as a
well-respected intellectual.
He was able to rise to
power or missed immediately,
but that's pretty far from the truth
has revolution. It was a long process,
but he never gave up trying to
sliver his way into a place of power.
Vladimir Lenin, he had a real
talent for stirring up trouble.
Even among the intelligentsia, he would
call anyone who disagreed with him.
His enemies sends the
sniveling bourgeoisie,
even though they were all
middle class socialists.
He had absolutely no patience for
anyone who did not agree with him,
100% during one of their meetings to
discuss their strategies about the
revolution.
He insulted some of the Socialists so
strongly that they got up and left while
they were gone.
He declared that his ideals were the
Bolsheviks or the majority while everyone
else was the Menshevik of
Air Corps minority party.
That a Bolshevik get stock from
that point on. So in 1904 let it,
and he gets a bit stressed out from
all of this debating and discussing his
philosophy as well as handing out
pamphlets and stuff like that.
Since he got rather real,
he decided to take it be a long hiking
holiday and the Swiss Alps with his wife,
but the Bolsheviks,
they continued that own revolutionary
work while he was gone in 1905 there was a
peaceful protest in Saint Petersburg
and front of the Winter Palace.
People held up signs, pleading for
better working conditions, all the ones,
it was an eight hour work day.
They even saying God saved the Sata
show that love and support for the royal
family,
but instead of listening to their requests
saw Nicholas the second ordered his
guards to shoot at the crowd.
Thousands of people died and it
became known as bloody Sunday people.
They were outraged in the,
began protesting for workers'
rights all across Russia.
When Lenin had the new c abruptly ended
his vacation in Switzerland and decided
to come back to Russia. He finally had
the opportunity that had been waiting for.
He began to preach to people that they
needed to organize and take action
against the sob.
He got that little too excited about the
idea of a bloody revolution and rotel.
They should pour hot acid
onto the royal gardens.
Got into specific details
of how to murder someone,
which was something that no
other revolution rewriter
had done before. However,
there was still not enough revolutionaries
willing to fight and kill people on
Lennon's behalf.
Many of the Bolshevik revolution raise,
they were exiled to Siberia and Lennon
fled to Switzerland's before he could be
arrested too.
Then world war one rolls around and that
basically puts a damper on everyone's a
revolutionary plans.
Sonic lists.
The second d left some Petersburg
to join his man on the front lines.
This all also left his wife Alexandra
in the care of their spiritual advisor.
Grigori rasp. Putin. Yep. Oh,
this men believed that he was
the second coming of Christ.
Didn't believe that he had magical
healing powers given to him by God.
Many of the decisions that recipes
in made were harshly criticized,
like putting is unqualified
friends in powerful positions.
If you want to learn more about Ras
Poussin the way we did a video about him,
find a link to that below Lennon and
still continue to write about his
revolutionary ideas from Switzerland's
and encouraged soldiers do tell him that
guns against their officers during
the war was almost no one was actually
reading the underground newspapers
is except for the handful of active
Bolsheviks.
The vast majority of the Russian people
were eager to defend their country,
but the war, it was still a
disaster. Millions of people died.
Inflation ruined Russia's economy and
women were standing in long bread lines.
Saw Nicholas the second
renames and peaches bag to
Petrograd Grad as a symbol of
his devotion to the
Russian people for years,
people that criticized the names and
Petersburg because it sounded too German
nuns Petrograd whois much
more Russian sounding saw.
Nicholas believed this would somehow
prove his loyalty, but the gesture,
it just wasn't enough for the first time.
Thousands of Russian people were trained
in the military and they knew how to
use guns, soldiers and
police officers. Well,
just as angry as the rest and people were
swarming the palace to take over from
the sauce all on their own Lennon
when he had nothing to do with it.
It wasn't even that he was
still in Switzerland and he
was panicking because the
revolution,
it was starting without him.
The political parties were
split into two groups.
The provisional government's which was
made up of the representative school,
the Duma and the workers,
Soviets who were controlled by the
trade unions and made up of the peasants
soldiers and factory work is letting
him knew that he was no match for the
provisional government's leader,
Alexander Kerensky.
He was a seasoned lawyer and
is a master of public speaking.
Kaminsky resonated with the tumor and
since Lennon was not actually a lawyer,
he knew that he would lose in
a political debate against him,
so therefore they then focus his efforts.
I'm trying to manipulate the lesser
educated workers. Soviets instead,
what are you arrived at the train station
then his friends with that degrees.
MNC hardly said hello before standing on
a pedestal to shout at the crowns that
they had to done an awful job with a
revolution and that it wasn't going to be
over until they took down the
provisional government's almost.
No one actually agreed with them and
they just carried on going about their
business even as felt Bolsheviks and
they're longer wanted to print his essays
because it was such an unpopular opinion.
The provisional government was leading
Russia back to war against Germany and
World War One. It was still going on, but
soldiers, they were not happy to serve.
It was the reason why that overthrowing
the siren in the first place.
People wanted the war to be over and
either abandoned their posts on the
battlefield or can keep you
refuse to go in the first place.
Then he tried to stand up again
and lead these crowds of peasants,
but someone from the
provisional government shouted
that he was a German spy.
This made the crown 10 against demons.
He had to run away.
Alexander Kerensky could see that he was
going to cause a lot of trouble for the
authority of the provisional government,
so he outlawed the existence of the
Bolshevik party Lenin. At this point,
he needed to escape. He was
on a bad wig, shaved his bids,
and Gus on the next train
to Finland's Vladimir Lenin.
He spent a very long time
hiding on a finish farm,
continuing to write his ideas
and send them back to Russia.
Since no one was actually listening
to him or agreeing with his ideas,
he decided to take Russia by force.
One night in October of 1917 he snuck
back into Russia and met up with his
comrades in Petrograd.
By this time,
he had convinced more members of
the Worker's Party to join us site.
He convinced his Bolshevik followers of
the red guards to break into the Windsor
Palace for a cuter top.
They captured members of the
provisional government's at gun points.
The dream that they were arrested,
taken to jail,
and Vladimir Lenin became the new leader
of Russia without ever being voted in
Bladimir and address the
crowd of Russian peasants.
That morning after storming the winter
palace and introduced himself as the new
dictator and as the leader
of the Soviet Union,
Lenin promised them exactly what they
wanted and he did it in the simplest words
possible peace, bread, and land.
One of his first acts as leader
was to bends the war with Germany.
People were happy because that's exactly
what they wanted all along right from
the beginning,
he isolated himself at the Kremlin in
Moscow so that he could continue writing
the Bolshevik party.
They wasted no time in
spreading propaganda that
Vladimir Lenin was like a kind
old grandfather who only wanted the best
for the Russian people and that they
didn't have to worry about anything
anymore. Everything was going to be fine.
Old granddaddy Lennon was going to
take care of you. In reality, though,
he was blood thirsty and he wanted his
revolution to be as violent as possible.
He told tenants to kill their landlords
and encouraged violence against the
upper classes.
He gave out the orders.
Who has read a gone to remove the
Romanov royal family from the palace.
At that time,
the number of men who joined in Lennon's
red guard had grown to 200,000 and he
had a small army to stand behind him.
Many of the Russian people,
they protested because
they love the Romanovs,
especially the young children at first.
Then in lied saying that they
would be kept somewhere safe,
but once he realized that they were
too much of a threat to his power,
he ordered their execution. Since
the family was being held in Siberia,
it took a very long time for the public
to learn about their deaths. At first,
people will leave.
There was just saw Nicholas,
he was killed and that the
women and children were spared.
It would take years for the public
to learn the truth of his brutality.
He proclaims that every Russian
citizens should have good rations,
but in order to do that,
the farms would have to be
controlled by the governments.
Farmers Web not allowed to keep or sell
the food they grew and all of the crop
swept spread out among the entire nation.
People could no longer choose their
jobs and were given employments in newly
constructed factory is based on
the needs of the country. Now,
some people were happy about this and it
gave them a sense of security. Indeed,
statues of Lenin were erected
around Petra grandsons.
Many people called him a hero. Now not
everyone was drinking Landon's Koolaid,
though plenty of people were furious
with him for ordering the death of the
innocent Rehmann off children.
In 1918 a woman named Fanya Kaplan
attempted to assassinate London.
She shot him twice at close range.
Now he was seriously injured,
but he still managed to survive.
Poplin was arrested and she refused
to give up the name of any of our co
conspirators. She was executed
in September of that same, yeah,
then it would recover from
his injuries in the hospital,
but from that day forward he showed no
mercy to anyone who expressed even the
smallest opposition to this rule.
Even though he always encouraged the
peasant class to stand up for their rights
and rebel against that government.
It was no longer okay to do so.
Once that was his government,
anytime peasants or farmers trying
to protest against his new rules,
they were killed without mercy.
Those who oppose London didn't
go down without a fight. Though.
In 1918 a group called the white army
battled against the Red Army and a civil
war fighting to take down
the Soviet Union. However,
the white army was not organized
very well and they lost the war.
In 1928 farmers were angry that their
green was being stolen from them for the
greater good of the communist nation.
This began what is known
as the tumble of rebellion,
but they were all gassed
by the Red Army runs.
Their crops were taken
away from their dead hands.
At least 50,000 people were in town,
mostly women, children and the elderly.
Some of them sent to campsis hostages.
There were several other incidents like
this and any rebellion among the Russian
people.
It was quickly squashed.
Even after trying to make as political
philosophy work through threats of death
and destruction,
Lennon knew wind call quince when millions
of people were on the brink of dying
from drought and famine.
He does something he did to temporarily
stop communism and allowed farmers to
keep the food that they planted and sell
the access food for profit. You know,
that's something called capitalism. And
surprisingly, this was a huge success.
People were no longer starving and
the economy improved once things had
stabilized again, Lenny went back to
forcing food rations. Unfortunately,
not every leader who followed in London's
footsteps knew when to take a break
from communism during a time of famine.
Lennon success of Joseph Stalin would
be remembered as one of the worst
dictators who ever lived
for this very reason.
Right
when he was in his 50s Vladimir Lennon's
health began to decline and he had
multiple strokes.
But even when he was in poor health,
he was trying to write in his journal
to give commands from his bed.
When he dies in 1924 people were shocked
as they were not expecting him to die.
So young hundreds of thousands of
people showed up to his funeral,
even though it was below
freezing temperatures, people
were sobbing, upset. This,
the one man who truly
cared about them was gone.
He did manage to make some improvements
in the economy and so there was so much
pro Lennon propaganda
that had been circulated.
The people believe that
he truly was their savior.
Five days after learning passed away,
the city of Petrograd was
renamed Leningrad in his honor.
His body was embalmed so that people
could continue to visit him and pay their
respects.
That Amir Lennon's reputation,
it only became more
powerful after his death.
He was like a legend who manage to change,
not just Russia,
but several other countries
throughout the world.
Communist leaders looked at him for
inspiration on how to run their own
dictatorships.
The USSR,
it continued for decades after his
death and despite all of its setbacks,
the system led to more
progress than Russia had seen
an hundreds of years before
Lennon.
The country was very far behind.
The rest of the Western world
in terms of industrialization,
education and modernization.
If it were not for all of the
reforms made by the Soviet Union,
they may have never gotten so far with
the space race against the United States,
and they still might be lagging behind.
Today,
in 1991 the Soviet Union collapsed
and all of the statues of Lennon,
they were torn down.
Instead of seeing him as a hero,
he has now remembered as a villain.
Lennon grants became Saint Petersburg.
Once again,
there is no telling how far the nation
would have progressed if it were not for
the creation of the Soviet Union.
But one thing is for sure,
without Vladimir Lenin, the world
would be a very different place today.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did, please do give us a thumbs up.
11 don't forget to subscribe. Also, if
you're looking for something else from me,
why not check out my other
channel called today?
I found out we do daily fact videos.
You'll find that links to below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.